hey Luke here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and welcome to another
episode today we got a fun V log with
loads of fishing trips and fun
activities with the whole family but
before we get into that I want to do a
special thanks for this video sponsor
the brat grabber mm yep brat grabbers
come out with another great product here
this is the 2000 model it's got an all
aluminum shaft great titanium assets
here on the ends and it is a very
affordable and functional product me and
Rebecca here use it all the time as you
guys know children often carry diseases
and the Brad grabber allows you to
restrict with them isn't that right
Jacob oh the extra grippy claws and
ergonomic handle allow you to really
control the child once you've made
contact and this product is extremely
effective for you parents out there you
know me and Rebecca find the Brad
grabber particularly useful when it's
bedtime Thomas come out from behind the
door you're going to bed
never oh that's it there you go get up
to bed get up to bed
the Brad grabber is also great for
getting down and it was hard-to-reach
places
there we go come on out it's bedtime hey
Nathan
does the Brad grabber work but the Brad
grabber doesn't just grab children it's
great for all sorts of household chores
the Brad grabber is lightweight
affordable and very durable
[Music]
if you guys want to know more about the
Brad grab or 2,000 check the video
description for a link and if you're
gonna buy one enter promo code outdoor
brats to get a discount well it is the
end of a very busy week I got absolutely
slammed at the office and didn't get a
lot of time to make videos this week so
I'm gonna be cramming a lot of stuff in
this weekend we're gonna take the boys
out fishing I'm gonna take Tommy out and
try out my new fly rod do some other
stuff around the house and we're just
gonna pack a lot into this video if
anyone who wants a haircut outside now I
have never given a haircut before so
today is the day
here's Tommy's hair just start off look
there we go buddy
that's old my hair that's a Chucky your
hair yeah
[Music]
yeah Wow
so one thing we need to do is your hair
sticking up all over the place so we
need to go and wash it really quick and
dry it so that it lays down right good
leave force there you go
all right let's go back cutting your
that's good they said look at me now
well then we got the haircuts down I'm
gonna go do a little fly-fishing with my
new three weight fly rod and I'm gonna
be taking Tommy with me unfortunately
Nathan is not happy with this all right
Tom follow me bud
[Music]
this one is pretty cool
[Music]
I'll bring them over here to me I'll
release there you go you just caught
fish in the fly rod
[Music]
there's three the large belfast but that
long they were chasing this guy
[Music]
some there's a little baby catfish this
crawfish so fast I got him
does he look
[Music]
great that strawberry-rhubarb yep there
you go Tommy I didn't they serve that to
you and literally in a boat we do put an
outboard on that it's a boatload of ice
cream right there is been eating a lot
of leftover steak and cheese sandwiches
this week oh I've got a stinky Jacob
here
oh yeah he's ripe time to load the but
Zuka ready
[Music]
okay daddy
[Applause]
[Applause]
Jakub you want another Jacob slam like
Jacob Slams we just sit here in the
front porch watching it rain something
about the summer's here in Virginia
whatever it's hot and humid in the
summertime you just guaranteed a nice
little Thunder burst in the afternoon
but they don't last too long so we might
still be able to go night fishing they
look up here we got a bird nest with
some baby birds in it under our awning
seems like every year that bird goes and
makes a nest and lays eggs there every
year they get eaten by something like
snakes and squirrels or something so
hopefully this year they won't die you
still got all those Legos from the Lego
fishing cabin gotta figure out what to
do with those they cost a lot of money I
really should use them for more than one
video what are you gonna go ride a bike
a little bit all right all right
Oh daddy's out of shape you really need
to get out and ride bikes more often
it's good exercise Tom loves it I also
got a multi-day biking fishing camping
trip I want to do with him we need to
get a little bit more practice first
[Music]
soldier here
I love you too buddy
hisses blows - [ __ ] all righty
thank you do you want to go fishing with
Daddy well my hero seven black came in
the mail today and we're giving it a go
something I'm noticing a little
different already getting almost 50%
more video footage on the same memory
card with the hero 7 so that's kind of
neat supposed to have stabilization a
little bit better audio better slow-mo
so I'm gonna try it out today see what
happens we're gonna see which we can
catch more of catfish or carp
let's go get some base shall we you got
that one Jake here let me get this one
for you
there we go there we go
yeah he's a dick he's a dick all right
come on Jake let's go
[Music]
okay
[Music]
I'm gonna try to keep it the rods every
other rod catfish and every other rod
carp and you know so forth because I
know you guys having fun in there well
not much has been biting this might turn
into the catch anything challenge here
real quick
yeah the bobber yeah oh yeah catfish
grabbed him there's a big tooth mark
right here his eyeballs popped out where
he got squeezed really hard like we got
a fight right there I got a bite right
there and a bite right there I got three
fish going at the same time come on i
spine me a little bit
yeah catfish they love this jello punk
oh sweet corn mix that is gorgeous isn't
it I should be going to bend all right
yeah you gonna stay up bud nice part
about a Friday night on a summer break
well it's getting late we're gonna pack
it up and head home but you know we had
fun lots of little bites one small
channel catfish I think that's pretty
much what's going on in this spot lots
of little channel catfish but we had a
good time and it was nice taking Jakob
out with us if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button so
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]